[Music]
they're separating us
from all our family but at the end of
the day
we messed up
[Music]
remember that the united states has a
tradition
to look for a scapegoat
[Music]
i don't think trump understands the
nature of the problem
this is the quinones neighborhood where
the two gangs are living
cheek by jowl on this side it's run by
barrio 18
and on the opposite side ms-13 and it is
deadly quiet
[Music]
have you lost any friends four friends
four friends killed in this job
i've had more than 50 friends die here
all different scenarios
[Music]
i wish i could have another opportunity
to go back to the states
but they said i can't go back
[Music]
now these days uh so you become to again
you got to kill
certain people
[Music]
[Applause]
donald trump has vowed to destroy ms-30
tonight i am calling on congress to
finally close
the deadly loopholes that have allowed
ms-13
and other criminal gangs to break into
our country
he zoned in on their brutality on u.s
soil to make the case for an
immigration crackdown they have
transformed
peaceful parks and beautiful quiet
neighborhoods into blood
stained killing fields
they're animals the gang's motto is rape
murder control
[Music]
america's relationship with el salvador
runs deep
it helped fund a bloody civil war there
it was only when refugees fled that
violence that ms-13 emerged
the group is american-made formed in los
angeles
when members were deported back in the
1990s it only made the gang
stronger president trump wants to do the
same
returning them to a country far deadlier
than the one they left
[Music]
it's not just criminals next year he's
cancelling permits that allow
two hundred thousand salvadorans to live
and work in the u.s
they were granted after two devastating
earthquakes
[Music]
el salvador's international airport and
are very nervous arrival
many of these deportees haven't stepped
foot in the country for decades
[Music]
their families and friends watch on
anxiously
he
[Music]
up to eight deportation flights arrive
here every week
today the buses are full and those
inside are about to begin a fight for
survival
[Music]
we're in le chakra it's a gang ridden
suburb of san salvador
and this is the main repatriation center
as you can see here the deportees
getting off the buses
for about an hour from the airport here
they're going to go inside
and speak to the authorities to find out
their fate
[Music]
they've spent weeks in detention centers
their few belongings bundled into bags
once inside their confiscated shoelaces
are handed back
some here were living in america
illegally some failed to follow the
immigration process properly
others openly acknowledged they
committed crimes
what do you think when you hear donald
trump saying he's sending back the bad
hombres
i mean what could i say he's right you
think he's right
we're not coming back for no reason so
you think you're one of those
i mean not that i'm one of them but at
the same time i committed a crime in the
u.s and
you know i'm eligible getting deported
then there's jefferson alvarado from
iowa he was nine when his mother took
him to the u.s to escape the violence
but he says she didn't turn up to an
immigration hearing and he was
eventually
sent back it's a new experience because
i pretty much grew up there
so and then coming back after 13 years
you don't know what to expect you know
because there's a lot of people here
with minor issues like driving without a
license
that to me that's not a criminal you
know so
and a lot of the people that are
actually getting
um into the criminal life they're still
out there
they're getting more of a chance and a
lot of people here
are actually hard workers
[Music]
i'm just looking forward to getting back
to my daughter and just
getting my life back
it was barack obama who deported more
people than any other president
no one knows what the next few years
will bring
[Music]
it's the next few hours that mata for
disorientated deportees
and they're walking straight into a
dangerous unfamiliar area
easy prey for the powerful gangs
[Music]
it's a perilous landscape for anyone to
return to
the government itself has become an
agent of violence taking an iron fist
approach to the two main gangs doubling
down in a country with the highest
murder rate in the world
for people under the age of 19. on the
day we arrive
23 people have been killed shootouts are
common
and soon enough we witnessed the
aftermath of one a suspected barrio 18
member
shot dead by police
in just the first 50 days of this year
there were 494
murders grief is on show
at nearly every turn
[Music]
we're on patrol with the national civil
police it's already a lethal dynamic on
the streets
now there's an influx of criminals from
america in the mix
and here they face far worse
[Music]
are you worried about the danger for you
yeah
about my family my partners around
all my people around me have you lost
any friends four friends four friends
killed
[Music]
the gangs run the capitals neighborhoods
and within minutes a busy bar catches
their attention
[Music]
just being out in this area is enough to
raise suspicion
and the room is quickly emptied
police say they believe that this is a
bar that's used by
gangs and they're searching these people
to try and look for any
tattoos perhaps any drugs weapons to
anything that might show membership
to certain groups
[Music]
but they don't find anything it is a
brief snapshot of a fragile atmosphere
the security forces have been accused of
carrying out extrajudicial killings
it's just seven o'clock and there is
little sign of life
the police see anyone in sight is a
potential threat
then just as officers are showing us
where they were ambushed
a call comes in another chase is on
[Music]
they find the car but no evidence this
game of cats and mouse is playing out
every night
the reality of living in one of the most
dangerous places on earth
a couple of days later suspected gang
members are paraded in front of the
cameras
a few weapons are discovered
and a hall of dollars
the gangs may not be seen as
sophisticated global cartels more like
mafias of the poor
but corruption and cover-ups have helped
protect them
[Music]
locking people up hasn't solved the
crisis the penitentiary system became a
hub for the country's gangs
we've gained rare access to apantios
prison
where they have a chance to redeem
themselves
[Music]
not everyone chooses to
america is sending criminals back to el
salvador
in the past gang members have been able
to regroup
and recruit in prisons
some even return to the us
at appentios there is at least a chance
to rebuild
you can study religion learn other
languages
even find out how to weave the hammocks
you sleep in
[Music]
but then we come across an extreme
contrast
inmates vying for space in cramped and
hot cells
el salvador's prisons are the most
crowded in the entire american continent
[Music]
some of the men tell us they've been
deported from the u.s
and they want to return i wish i could
have another opportunity to go back to
the states
but they said i can't go back because
they just they said i can't go back for
10 years
what do you think about that i mean i
wish i could go back
but i can
do you regret what you did everything
there were people that were a mess you
know you can't just walk out the door
and say hey
look i want i don't want to be nothing
you can't just say that
you know because once y'all leave
they kill me there are
plenty of opportunities to rehabilitate
here
lots of ways to learn but even if many
of these people do want to leave the
gangs escaping their clutches
can be very difficult the reality is
membership
can be its own life sentence
estimated there are 60 000 active gang
members in a country of under
six and a half million people and
america
is unloading more adding to a problem el
salvador is trying to contain
[Music]
this isn't a country rich in natural
resources
but there is one thing that can be
exploited
people supportees can try to scratch a
living in some of the markets making
maybe five dollars a day in some of
these stalls but it can be hard to keep
hold of what little
they do make they have to pay a levy to
the gangs
extortion here is right
the economy also depends on the money
people send back
from the us it accounts for roughly 17
of its gdp
that could fade fast and the job market
can't easily absorb
tens of thousands of people returning
either
[Music]
good morning my name is billy conway
from the brave stalker how are you today
[Music]
ironically one of the best ways to make
money as a deportee
is taking calls for u.s companies
there are 10 major firms operating here
employing some 20 000
people eddie anzora a deportee himself
is teaching others how to master the
language of american customer service
the call center industry is pretty big
right now is and it keeps growing
but it doesn't grow as quick as it
should because
they still need more english speakers
sorry
his pain is never far from the surface
you just keep going and
[Music]
i don't look back you just live here
but i've had more than 50 friends
die here all different scenarios
waiting on the bus stop
[Music]
going to a sister's wedding
we're on the road to asulatan a rural
town about 60 miles east of san salvador
we're hoping to catch up with jefferson
who we met at the repatriation center
he's so scared of being spotted by the
gangs he'll only speak to me in our van
this street may seem pretty normal
pretty calm
but there might be like three four
people just watching out
you know what i mean so and that's the
only thing that
you know you don't know what to expect
if i'm not go out
then it's it's it's a problem letting
people know where i'm at
because at any time they can just show
up to my house and just kill me
or try to hurt my family just in case
i'm not there
do you think your tattoos will be an
issue yes because
all the tattoos here they're
pretty much the gang members are the
only ones that carry them
here it's it's a sign of being a gang
member
or being a criminal
jefferson's future is now in the hands
of el salvador's government
but it claims the issues have been
exaggerated
it is a responsibility of our government
to provide for our citizens
right so but uh let's remember to uh
president trump
that the immigrants coming in across the
border
and not only salvadores we are just only
a small percent
this is a small country and yet you're
never far away from a potentially
horrifying scene and we're about to see
one unfold
middle of the day we're about an hour
outside of the capital and you can see
a young man's body just there
[Music]
it's her son
raw grief engulfs the active crime scene
in the heart of ms-13 country
and a mother must wait as others pour
over her child's body
[Music]
we're told his name is jorge he's 18
and he's got two gunshot wounds one to
the chest
and another to the head
the grim choreography of an
investigation plays out
finally his body is removed from the
stifling sun
his mother asked for the one thing she
can hold on to
his shoes
[Music]
no one knows what the toll of the new
wave of deportations will be
[Music]
sending gang members back could
ultimately make ms-13
stronger but america's patience and
hospitality
is running dry and it's now el
salvador's problem alone
once again washington's firm hand could
shape
the country's fate
there is no short answer there is no
magic one
here you know like harry potter no
we are dealing with social problems we
are dealing with human lives
[Music]
i'm here and i made my life whatever but
as far as um
can i get killed i'm not doing nothing
wrong so if i get killed it's just
probably like
part of the the the statistics or you
know a bunch of people who don't care
about their lives
um there's no hope for these guys some
of these guys like
it's because it's too easy
what do you think it's going to do to
your generation
it's uh it's keeping me away from my
family from my daughter
it's time that i'm missing from her and
i'm
at the point in time where it could be
that i could never get to see her again
[Music]
you